I've,
I've gone around and spoken and a large
proportion of my audience has been young
man.
He,
you know,
under 30 something like that.
And I've spoken to them a lot about
responsibility.
And what's so odd about,
about this is that of all the things
that I've spoken about,
cause I can see the audience and I can
feel how the audience is reacting
because I'm always paying attention to
all of you.
It's in so far as I can manage that.
So I get some sense of how what I'm
saying is landing,
you know,
which you have to do if you're going to
speak effectively to people.
And what,
what happens is if I talk about
responsibilities,
everyone b is silent just like they are
now.
It's silent and,
and not moving,
right?
Focusing attentive.
Say Pick up your responsibility,
pick up the heaviest thing you can and
carry it.
And the room goes quiet and everybody's
eyes open.
And I think that always makes me break
up.
I was,
I don't,
I don't know why I was speaking to an
English journalist today who's going to
write an article in spectator magazine.
I was talking about this and at the same
point in the discussion the same,
I had the same emotional reaction.
I don't really understand it.
It's,
I think it's something,
there's something about it that's so
crucial because you know,
we've been fed this on ending diet of
rights and freedoms and there's
something about that especially,
there's something about that that so
pathologically wrong and people are
starving for the antidote.
And the antidote is truth and
responsibility,
right?
And it isn't.
It isn't because that's what you should
do.
And some,
you know,
in some,
some I know better or someone knows
better for you,
what you should do.
Since it's that,
it's that it's that,
it's that that's the secret to a
meaningful life.
And without a meaningful life,
then all you have is suffering and
nihilism and despair and all of that and
self contempt.
And,
and that's not good.
And so the man,
it's necessary for men to stand up and
take responsibility and they all know
that and are starving for that message.
And the message is more that that's also
a good thing to stand up and take
responsibility because you're cursed so
much now from,
from,
from when you're young with this notion
that your active engagement with the
world is part of what is destroying and
undermining the planet and adding to the
tyranny of the social systems.
It's like,
how about not so much of that,
hey,
because it's,
it's,
it's two soul deadening.
It's anti human right to the core.
And my sense instead is that,
you know,
if you,
if you were able to reveal the best of
yourself to you in the world,
that you would be an overwhelming force
for good.
And that whatever errors might be made
along the way would wash out in the
works.
And that's the other thing that you see
in the abrahamic stories.
Because Abraham is not a perfect person
by any stretch of the imagination.
He's a real person and he makes
mistakes,
but it doesn't matter.
The overarching narrative is,
you know,
maintain your covenant with God and
despite your inadequacies,
then not only will you prevail,
but your descendants will prevail.
It's like,
great,
that's really good news.
You know?
So it's been really something to see
that in the,
in the stories.